the phillies have just honored the
veteran infielder longtime infielder
manny trio
with some space on the philly's wall of
fame philadelphia has not won seven
straight in nine years and they will try
to do it today with ranger suarez
starting for them this afternoon brings
up pete alonso alonso
the 251 average 24 home runs on the
season
another one-two swag and a miss he got
him threw him a sinker at 94 got his
first strikeout
how to bring jd davis to the plate
short lead off first and the 2-2
and a strike three called on the outside
corner
back-to-back k's for suarez
two men away and javier baez coming up
suarez with a 3-2
and that will be taken
suarez again not real happy with the
call on that they missed inside
and that'll bring up brandon drury
tap her back to the bounds
it's a hard work at first he wipes his
brow and then throws to first base
he is unfazed no runs no hits two men
left
middle of the first police coming up as
for tylor mcgill well he's the last mid
starting pitcher to earn a win and it
came july 23rd against the blue jays one
down gene segura will be the batter 2-2
pitch
swing and a liner towards first diving
stop by alonso gets up dives for the bag
touches up ahead of segura for the out
terrific play by pete alonso so here is
harper
and a swing and a miss good job miguel
has a one two three inning to kick it
off and after one in philadelphia
vr was one for four last night three and
two here's the pitch swinging and this
he struck him out well that's a fastball
way off the plate away
not sure what vr was thinking on that
that'll bring up kevin palar
one two pitch swing at a miss he got him
fourth strikeout for ranger suarez
there's a one two three second inning
we'll go to the bottom of the second
fills nothing in the mets nothing
real muto
on a six-game hitting streak is betting
274 with 12 homers 51 runs batted in
payoff pitch swung on and missed strike
three rio muto looked like he was
looking for something else on three and
two very late on a fastball as he swings
and misses and mcgill has a second
strikeout and brad miller the first
baseman two and two the count on miller
now mcgill deals
swinging and a miss strike three a fast
ball away and now tyler mcgill has
struck out three in a row he's retired
all five phillies that he's faced now
the batter will be the pitcher jd hammer
he's only had one at bat in his career
he sold for one and uh he's over two
see you later got him out of there one
two three inning what a way to start
five years 115 million that's what it
took to keep real muto in philly
he has been great lately 12 for his last
28
with runners in scoring position that's
a 429 average that dates back to july
9th
one ball two strikes on jt real muto two
outs herrera at second
mcgill's pitch
swinging a missed strike three fastball
ran up and in 96 miles an hour and how
about that from tylor mcgill and that
will bring up tylor mcgill payoff pitch
mcgill hits it hard on the ground fair
down the third baseline an extra base
hit going into the corner herrera
hustling after it or at least
moving after it finally gets to it
lays it back in and tylor mcgill is
standing at second with his first career
extra base hit
and that'll bring up pete alonso
alonso for one a strikeout and a walk in
his two plate appearances against
ranger suarez and now he faces jd hammer
the 2-1
and alonso hits a smash to third bowm
knocks it down runs to get it throw to
first and it's dug out by miller and he
is out at first phase
great scoop by brad miller alec baum
stays with it and the mets are done in
their half
of the fifth we'll go to the bottom of
the fifth at citizens bank park phil's
nothing in the meds nothing
here's brad miller to lead it off miller
a
226 hitter on the air with 10 homers
fly ball right center field that's well
hit that's not coming back it is gone
into the full pin
brad miller puts the phillies on the
board
it's a one-nothing game
brad miller with his 11th of the season
solo shot one-nothing phillies
i'll tell you what he could hit some far
balls that's 437.
here is odouble herrera he had that
double his last time up he blasts one
way back to right and that's a game
changer
second deck for o'double herrera three
run home run his first homer in this
ballpark this year wow
oh
four to nothing phillies lead
muto today has struck out twice
the 0-1 there's a high pop foul outside
first playable
alonso on the grass makes the catch
jonathan vr coming up here's the pitch
to vr and he swings and drives it down
the left field line pretty deep oh
double to the corner going over races
makes the catch right up against the
fence
nice running catch by o'double herrera
in the corner
and we are retired so are the mets
no runs no hits and air and a man left
and we'll head for the bottom of the six
now it's the phillies four in the mets
nothing
gene is one for three on the day had an
infield hit
he has the 02
and it hit him oh no
it didn't get it square which it doesn't
appear
yeah it might have gotten more on the
hand than it did the mouth
so segura is going up to first hit by a
pitch
luke williams is going to stay in the
game and play second base
brad miller hit a home run earlier that
home run
was his 11th of the year the phillies
have six guys who have reached double
digits at home runs
only the giants have more that one's out
toward left palar going back it is gone
he went off oh
he pulls one into the bullpen in right
center field and brad miller
has another multi-home run game
this one goes the opposite way
and it's five nothing phillies
benfordo up to lead it off here in the
ninth inning
1-1 pitch conforto hits it deep to right
field this is in orbit a long home run
into the second deck
by michael conforto
and so the mets get on the board the
phillies lead
is cut to five 5-1 that is his 125th
career home run so here's jonathan vr
the 1-2 the audience it in the air deep
to right this ball is back at the wall
and this ball's gone back-to-back home
runs against mauricio giovera first by
conforto now by vr
it is five to two philadelphia
and now it's a safe situation for ian
kennedy james mccann is due to hit here
he is grounded to short slide to right
and taking a call third strike oh and
one to mccann here's the pitch swinging
a high fly ball to deep right field
harper back at the track that's gone
the hat trick back to back to back home
runs by conforto vr and now mccann
and the mets
have loudly come right back into this
game here in the ninth inning nobody out
philly's five nets three
j.d davis ready to stand in
the count one and two to jd davis the
pitch swag and a miss he got him
seven in a row for the fells
a big time save for ian kennedy